everybody what's going on play here
welcome to Monday May thank you for
joining us this this week we're very
excited to have coming over from Playboy
and the web series gamer next door
Pamela Horton and Amelia Talan that's
right also Beth is in the chat room
Stephen on the ones and twos and Jason
O'Malley creeper there we go thank you
for joining us today we're gonna be
playing a fun little indie game about
tiny brains where we're lab rats trying
to escape the lab the best one you know
what let's just see let's see we got
your escape the med lab and maybe if we
get sick of this we can go tiny soccer
if if we can't figure out how to escape
the laughs let's see nope continue
public there we go all right join up
join up hit X I didn't actually figure
out how to do that way here we go it's
gonna go offline this is what we do I
played this game for four minutes now
they all have different powers they like
their powers all right I'm gonna be
where are you you know they're all
different animals alright I'm gonna be
there this dude looks sad he looks by
the way half his brain yeah half his
brain although also we can change to the
fourth player during this game also so
it's like because I think all right so
you switch character all right that's
right where are you your [ __ ]
oh wait see this soso hit to hit the
directional pad to change
there you go nope alright wait okay
exes jump exes jump that's okay we'll
figure it out
exit jump our two is your thing no you
who are you you're alright you alright
Amelia you have the power of
teleportation so when you aim at stuff
you switch places with it that's how you
got the block out of the thing you see
them saying we're trying to get the
block over to that thing over there
which I don't know how we're gonna do it
and then yeah nice job you pail you have
oh you can draw stuff towards you
with your powers and I don't know I
guess I just make big blocks yeah there
we go
all right all right here we go we can
get up here using the blocks
oh the case I think we destroyed the
block from the wait hold on wait hold on
I think we have to get if there's stairs
here I think we gotta get wait so come
on this is good guys we're gonna use
teamwork okay we're gonna have to work
together all right so wait
my pet Pamela you can you make this
there stairs here can you pull the block
back yeah back over here yeah all right
perfect
all right now can you pull these stairs
out using your powers yeah and you aim
you aim with the right stick hey with
the right stick
don't press all the buttons we might end
up playing soccer we'll see called tiny
brains t work is for nerds AC would yeah
well we're nerds figure it out so yeah
if you could be like hey hey lookit come
over here and do that right so these are
stairs or you see the blue arrow these
are stairs right here these are stairs
all right so we got to get those stairs
out somehow how do we do that
does anybody know oh wait a second wait
why don't I use my party jump up here
there we go there we go right we're just
lab animals alright alright we got the
stairs by the way this is just the
tutorial thanks alright yeah so try
pulling the block up there there we go
see if you can pull the block up wait a
minute wait Amelia maybe you try can you
aim at the block and and zap it up to
where we're going hi Barry 78 build your
ice brick up okay maybe I'll hold on
maybe I'll try this ice break it's a
it's the right trigger it's the right
are two aren't you but you got to aim at
the thing you might not be able to shoot
down there yeah you might not be able to
shoot down
I feel like can you build the ice block
underneath it so we can yeah wait that's
a good point that's it let me try to do
that only goes underneath me wait what
about if I get on top of this though
check this out
that's [ __ ] we're defying this is
ridiculous
wait guys what if what if this game only
has one level if you can only play this
level all right oh wait nice job well
done well done
high five high five high five oh yeah
then we do the singles down below then
we do the tickle summer this summer
high fives are blast summer tingles of
this summer so alright here we go
alright great now we just gotta get how
do we do that well you know you shoot
you know what I feel like there's yeah
alright my brick thing is not gonna work
yeah how do we do we think that this
closes or something that this part close
wait maybe I should switch to this other
dude how do I do that I think this dude
I think we want this other guy which is
how do I change that guy wait hold on
should we all right we can't attract it
towards it you can't change your places
with that I think we got to become
player two but you know what player two
I think because we've turned on this
controller there's no rules here alright
see this guy shoves stuff away
this guy's yeah they wanted to drink
during their run can we drink because
I've always got whisky in my life
and I could by the way I'm from Michigan
so can we call it pop please it's true
name pop soda there we go I'm fine with
that
I like that accent all right let's see
here all right I think it's right I'm
gonna try
see this guy shoots it across is that
true that Sibelius thing is killing us
no way you got you guys have gate game
Rex door right which today by the way
I'm on the episode of game racks doors I
go to youtube.com slash gamer next door
/i just what you know I sacrifice my you
saw you celebrate by killing yourself
all right get back up on the goddamn
stairs see we're learning all right here
we go all right now we did it
[Music]
let's go let's go
how do I want to get rid of this other
guy I'm gonna turn this controller off
wait can I do something boring quickly
okay now let's see here
we want to get we want to get over there
how do we do this I feel like it's we're
gonna need to teleport blade do I call
it micro flute or do I call it a sweeper
or vacuum no I call a vacuum of vacuum
and a sweeper like a broom the broom is
a sweeper yeah unless you're talking
about soccer
waste paper people call it a waste paper
oh I just call it garbage I caught the G
file I'm gonna follow this in the G file
I've been working at office way too long
wait what do you what do you call it you
call it a Davenport or a sofa or a couch
have you ever heard the word Davenport
yeah they only town named after a couch
all right let's see here now wait what
the hell do we do which one of us can
get across Amelia can you teleport
something across anything oh wait wait
ice guy ice guy here we go here we go
ice guy can make his thing all right we
did it right now can you teleport yes
perfect
don't worry I you know what I'll make an
ice block you just hold on for a sec
cause your horses you just hold your
horses whoo all right everybody on the
ice block ready get close to me here
yeah yeah
ready making a pig
I basically [ __ ] ice in this game that's
my superpower [ __ ] all right here we
go
get close no okay okay we get over here
get over here every clique come over
that's a good question you watched it
sideways at an angle all right here we
go here we go okay that was my fault
that was my fault that's my fault
I just you know what just get it back
over he get back over here all right
here we go ready all right this is not
working
all right you know what just jump on the
ice block can you jump over no all right
can't get over closer to me all right
here we get ready yes great job
[Music]
can we take a quick break I'm gonna turn
figure out it I'm just gonna turn this
controller off because this is just
killing me killing my heart turning my
soul I took while we're waiting tell
people about gamer next door gave her
next door is well done watch it there
you go
nailed it now we're we're we're a groovy
set of girls girls groovy we're greedy
groovy groovy goofy girls no we we play
a lot of we play a lot of video games we
most recently had a what do you think of
blood-borne I liked it the games nope
nope hardest game over no no you played
not play Dark Souls then no Dark Souls
well then you you you okay so I have a
Dark Soul I need to play Dark Souls but
if you play Dark Souls you go oh
blood-borne actually not that bad really
yes oh never play we wanna make a hard
game but not too hard
there we go I do appreciate the giant
axes they have the transfer me
transform your weapon so like there's
this one where you have a sword that
turns into a hammer
alright the cane that turns into a whip
which is by the way really what what do
you mean what do you mean I don't know
how to get rid of this other fourth guy
so maybe let's just say that's a great
idea
Steven do you want to play this fourth
player please turn it off but the guy
didn't disappear just pick a guy already
all right I'm gonna get the guy all
right so your power is you yell it and
jump on the guy's do another thing ready
[Music]
playboy model is better than Aaron at
games never imagine that yeah imagining
and there's it's happen what's the
button I press r2 don't want to do it
yet oh god Talan yeah by the way Steve
it's hair on point today I just didn't
wear half didn't wear a hat great hair
though great hair you guys also yes
pretty great what's going on down there
sumo chick big fat chicken if you have
to chicken
it's a it's one of those swifty sweepers
what are they called but the street
sweepers moving it's got like creatures
on it well it's back he's cleaning up a
bunch of creatures big wreck Aaron gets
so into the game yeah man no no it's
just wanted us to read all the couches
I'm not sure oh you know what wait I
think we have to move the cat oh oh oh
oh wait wait oh wait and roll it down
the thing that was really scary but now
not so we know don't let it fall down
here guys nice job good job
it's a Pam or Pamela all right
is it a meal or Amelia Amelia Oh
actually can we have a brown
don't lose the ball alright so let's get
this ball going nice job oh there we go
no no wait wait do the do the teleport
do the teleport across the way nice well
done that's okay oh great great job
great job don't push the ball into the
way exactly wait do that again that was
great
what Ninja Gaiden ps4 no we haven't we
haven't played Ninja Gaiden on ps4 Ninja
Gaiden by the way one of the games when
I was a kid it could never get past a
certain level and it's haunted me since
I I think you could just almost and two
people died yeah expert ball control
that's right pretty good at handling
balls in video games when you're playing
a lab rat game get your mind up oh dude
you just power just powered it over
there whoa I don't know if we're playing
smart on purpose all right I can't push
it by the way consume me it's way too
heavy for my character oh freezers no I
got the guys are hopefully really
screwing today it's all bleh Oh a brick
mold
yeah me too Eric could never get past my
levels I know it's the level ironically
where you're like fighting your father
which I think says a lot about my life
could never get past that level
oh that breaks good to know note to self
I'm not helping it all here I guess you
know what I you know what I can do is
stop it from going down here we go
I can just keep putting this up so it
stops from falling down and I block yeah
I'm just learning that um no wait you
guys how did you guys first get into
gaming what was the first game you play
damn there we go what would s Miglia
what about you games would you what's
the first game you remember Floyd or
your favorite game really oh my god I
was never a big fan of okay well I was
gonna sit it's a terrible singing voice
I vote you because good question wait I
stink I stink now we're dead blades
underneath wait should I do a thing
right at this there's a template right
there where you should be doing I see
the blue square oh here we go
Oh see you're so smart and then and then
I push you forward oh great
all right ready oh yeah nice job wait
guys now I'm stuck in this pit oh wait
here I can guess I can get this edge on
how do I get the thing understand that
you need to stand next to it and face us
oh it goes behind you no it goes off
here
with it when I did that it when I do
that - it goes in front of me wait wait
I just need to give it a little space
yeah we did that so things are even
watching the stream face you know fellow
right here oh here here yeah how did
that work I was facing you I'm gonna
kill myself so you have to push me
across
yeah you know what yeah oh very yeah way
better
don't send a man to do a lady's job cuz
the ladies are so much better at this
than the men are all right here we go
oh dude great job you know I'm really
good at this game is just pushing I'm
not gonna use my powers I'm not good at
figuring things out I'm just like derp
bleh move this way
Frankenstein push this this way like how
this game has like a Rapids feel like
Rayman Raving it really does yeah it
really does where is Jordan in his
office probably looking at different
olive oils oh you can oh we can we just
learn me to push this thing where's the
block somebody has to teleport across in
the press that button you mean the only
person who can teleport Emilia or or you
can do a nice thing again let's do a
nice thing we'll do nice thing we like
the ice
that was good how's that ice thing good
here wait yeah yeah wait yeah let's just
put here just get on the ice thing oh
yeah there is a me though and a meet I'm
just saying guys we're doing really well
yeah nice keep gonna ask my boyfriend
for a honeymoon to go to LA to see a
taping of Conan he was not going for lol
micro flotilla give me your phone number
and address that will come to your house
and get beat up by your boyfriend slink
away
yeah slink away after everybody on the
ice boat let's go that's like that magic
trick where you pull that
can you just push us normally no I just
try their work what about oh yeah this
work
oh no now we need you can't teleport
with her can you so you talk more later
you need to go you need to go over there
jumper up and then she pulls there okay
let me just die real quick
I'm just kill myself in preparation for
doing this I know what do I do
yes so now bleh you trick you do the
jump up thing and then she'll pull it
off oh I see okay ready ready go do it
yeah what tingles going on wet tingles
all right how do we get back across to
me can you we can't we could just die
and then you could teleport nice wait
maybe you can jump up on me try jumping
up on that try yeah try jumping up on
the ice block totally don't have this
you got crazy hops and Isaiah gr NT
Connie might show up later hopefully
we're hoping he's got a lot to shoot
today but we'll see here wait yeah there
we go here we go all I had to do is die
and I Oh perfect all right all right
nice boat somebody want to pull the
Block on there with you Wow good job all
right now we need you to shoot it okay
just jump this entire time yell it over
there perfect
Oh micro foot so that's so cool
Conan words got me through some rough
times I feel the class had a way to year
to graduate just like me yeah that's a
great speech by the way Beth's is gonna
link to the Dartmouth speech in in the
chat you guys should see it it's great
yeah smart dude way smarter than me just
died because I wasn't paying attention I
don't know let's shoot a block at it
she'd a block at it so what are some of
the what are some of the games you guys
are playing gamer next day that you're
most excited we all in one motion how
John Oliver is I was on John Oliver but
I never actually met him and he tweeted
about me cuz well no but I never
actually met him actually I had more
people calling me and getting upset that
I didn't tell them I was gonna be on
John John Oliver tells everybody playboy
did this thing we're either making fun
of the sexy costumes for people like sex
tape a movie in fact a nurse since we
were sexy I was sexy George are Martin
sexy john oliver sexy cross sagen i live
my life is sexy Erin Blair it's a
costume I wear every morning I know it's
a terrible no it's it's ironic Thursday
it's like calling a big guy tiny sexy
Erin but so it actually got attention
from John Oliver and he put it on his
show Oh Austin the way that we did the
images is that's my name in the middle
of it so although a lot of people could
even tell it was me
it said my name on it so I got like
texts and why did you tell me I was
gonna record it you need to be ready to
grab the block okay okay so I'm gonna
push him over there gotcha
my trap maybe maybe we should how close
do you have to be to pull it off should
we just do it closer yeah I think it's
just me and then wait so how I don't
understand what's gonna happen she's
gonna oh god it got it got it okay all
right ready perfect
Mason dude cool I'll see that in a bit
oh I've last week tonight record last
week tonight great show great show yeah
I wasn't I wasn't centered you gotta let
me Center myself before you launch me
over okay so awesome that was awesome
well done well done now what oh wait no
we just got to push it under the thing
but why is there confetti coming down
into lab environments if you like weird
this I feel bad for the chipmunk with
the helicopter stapled to his head
being purified exactly being shower just
Axe body spray
why do I feel like this is gonna be
terrible push the ice block and kill the
chickens Oh God
ice block kill chickens yeah there we go
nice get that get that one oh they're
horrible wait sorry I'm not doing this
right didn't teleporting towards us is
not gonna help yeah nice I like how
you're crushing them by pulling the
block towards us is so mean oh yeah I'm
gonna start not next week for the week
after I'm gonna start doing twitch from
my house which will be fun also you know
pants optional we'll see what happens I
just range from the waist up that's well
exactly that's true
yes streaming from the waist up you
should see a doctor about that oh oh oh
I like it so you pull them pull them
down with you
big chicken guy with the baby chickens
chicken stick I know he looks awesome oh
my god good point because it's a puzzler
so the risk is bored oh you guys are
just joining us we're here with the host
of game host of gamer next door play me
calm Emilia Talan and Pamela Horton see
this man and you can see their thing
youtube.com slash or forward slash gamer
next door and follow these guys at
Pebble horn 13 and at Amelia Talent
[Music]
thank you thank you
I'm dead I'm dead inside and I do it all
the time here we go let's get that thing
over there
nice this isn't even a problem for us
guys we're killing all so we're playing
tiny brains which is a little indie
puzzle platformer which is really fun
where we're all different labs are you
rabbit what are you you're a rabbit
look gopher okay cuz Gophers are blue
that makes sense nice jump over
blob 3:52 chicken nuggets actually made
from chicken that's true chicken nuggets
one of my favorite foods let's go all go
through and see our favorite food
mine chicken well chicken nuggets or
pizza rolls or crunchy Cheetos broccoli
broccoli no it's really good I bet you I
bet you you would enjoy it right is
there are we talking cheese what else is
in the broccoli is cream of mushroom
Ritz crackers on the top oh my god it's
really good that sounds absolutely
disgusting
I can't imagine anything worse Emilia
what's your favorite food anything
whatever's closest whatever is closest
if you ever Java favorite junk no I got
them all right can I just slowly
crushing rock really anything in the
ramen not like oh oh I see real Robin
beep that's actually like yeah not top
the broth yeah I'm trying ah sorry guys
I like I like freaking up here I create
I like creating a block and just slowly
crushing them they can just feel their
insides and popping it's that crazy to
say Montessori diet of Champions goddamn
right look at these guns these are pizza
rolls all on these muscles not really
it's just it's [ __ ] and a lot of diet
coke and coffee here we go here we go
here we go get behind the block
he's killing the baby chick guys don't
even want all we wanted protect them
neither block sorry
yeah block get him get him
can we get like shoot him up on top of
the thing so he's just far away there we
go
there we go hey what is this dude's
problem it's a giant chicken in a diaper
what's happening there yeah
can somebody help me crushing whoo my
powers refresh rate is like way too slow
if I had a nickel for every time oh
that's a good yeah who's gonna think
oops
I shoot this block behind me I kick nice
job only for waves to go all done just
kill these chicks
oh I can
get in there oh nice oh wow
oh no wait now we have to now that was
closed I hope whatever scientist is
watching this is happy
hey get him in there oh man I wish I had
to push power yes
Lina skater
I can jump on them oh that's cool oh my
god I am oh oh yeah we can just jump on
them that is so useful
see guys oh that's great
quick get this guy in the thing block
out a thing
dang it babies under his tag what do you
help oh no oh [ __ ]
where am I hello why how do I get the
top
what are you doing oh wait that's you
get him in the thing nice oh my god nice
job guys that's job
behind-the-back tangles under the arm
singles all right mr. roller what you
guys gonna play league of legends I
learn how to play oh my god you have a
character with your character
[Music]
Frenchy 2018 oh my god don't make you a
leaguer I'll never quit that's true it's
like you can't smoke just half a crack
rock you know what I'm saying I feel
like I haven't started League of Legends
cuz it's just gonna like take over my
entire look at the finish one crack rock
and know that there's more but you
stopped yourself well you stopped
yourself cuz you have self-control yeah
you remember the whole thing about pizza
rolls yeah alright wait I'm gonna make a
nice thing behind it here
Oh Neil you know the other person who
can teleport did it support ultimate
league stereotype I'll remember that
next time when someone will play support
but a little closer yeah exactly
I'm filling roles that you don't want to
[ __ ] play so shut your mouth exactly
yeah not everybody yeah the heat it's
like I got played support role right now
and doing a pretty good job well you
have to play bio so I can't for now they
beat that game dude come on
well play it on here though that game is
fun I love Bioshock although I think by
oh she's the first woman so creepy yeah
plus there's like super shock value
sorry
well well done we're up dog Amelia get
up there get up there ball got on the
ice block get any Oh Tiger Woods well
done guys I don't even play league and
she's gonna call me up for no you
stereotype yeah exactly cash cat there's
a cash a cat yeah you feel like you're
gonna need them nails
oh good job wait did somebody touch you
teleport the nails over oh god what
happened we got better we can always
jump on these things too - hey play put
a nice block on top of this okay yeah
don't tell me how to live oh wait here
we go
fallout 4 OS for the guys oh wait
somebody has to stand on that button so
me and bleh doesn't stand on the buttons
blame a cannot make a nice thing all
right yes guys we're killing this game
shut up evil scientist your day
wait oh yo the best platform is for
after we get it so a let's do this
oh wait she's on so wait what do we need
to do still wait we gotta go we gotta
get a ice block over there to shoot
Amelia up too so she can teleport the
thing out yeah we don't care about this
right away yet or can you teleport it
across the whole thing just call me the
ice block man nice man mr. freeze the
ice block can stay in anything yeah and
then and then when it launches you up as
its melting waffle tarts this lab has to
be making numerous safety populations
yes
what kind of wait what is that glowing
green stuff that can't be healthy me see
the block over no but we can jump I can
jump I can jump can you teleport the ice
block you can't right you know
wait so wait what does that button do oh
that brings down the shields God got it
alright so alright let's just wait can
you can you suck the thing over if we're
on it there you go
everybody got the ice block
nice alright so we now get an ice block
get on the thing right we'll shoot you
up boom even with the extra family you
stay on that okay okay
and then what what are we doing now guys
just die and you'll respawn okay so now
we do the ice blocking to do the same
thing we were doing before right yeah
nice well done alright so now okay now I
have to get off of this and she has to
shoot it across or someone else to take
your blade stand on the button oh yeah
here we go yeah that's how we do I'm
just doing running take oh yeah yeah
Jenaya let's just do the flopper now
we'll just do the flop flip flop
okay I volunteer blade to get on that
alright fair enough
wait the flopper get the flopper on the
rising thing here we go get your ice
block off the button oh right geez Satan
such a tone haha
you think you give me a warning okay
wait alright I'm ready
do it why did I do what did it do let me
tell me that part right okay here we go
ready I'm on the block
you need to get to that button guys
herself back up we'll alternate so that
the block stays oh I did it oh this is
handy jump on the thing I wanna jump
over and then somebody's and push that
other foot okay okay come over here come
over here
alright stay on that thing wait let me
you gotta jump up the button for a
little bit but get back right back home
keval go blood love you all from the
bottom I heart we love you too baby come
on let me get on there okay so now what
no perfect we did it now like our like
our descriptions just put the things put
also do this day you can also move
around with the touch map you need to
talk to maybe if you're playing online
that's an easier way to do all right
this way it's a break it's really fun
okay if you're just joining us for
playing tiny brains with gamer next
door's Pamela Harden and Amelia Talan at
Kayla Hornet 13 at Amelia Talan I would
be kind of nice I do need to redecorate
my apartment let's just put that couch
down there for now yeah I think I think
it looks good yeah you could punctuated
throwing it into the green pit
the energy oh sorry that was somebody
jump over the other thing nailed it
nailed it well then I get it I get it
somebody put yeah oops sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry didn't think about that
alright buddy that's okay we can get
over it I hear you jump over to that
this does feel I wonder if this is made
by the same the Raving Rabbids
nice right in the hole good ball smash
by you going we have to use them to blow
stuff up what do we want to have them
blow oh there we go no it's got a tiny
brain like it said it didn't warn us
that it has
yes oh my god remember we can jump on
these guys - we can we can just burn
them Oh a good idea oh I see Oh teleport
yeah yeah gas and fire somebody I'm on
the gas I'm on the gas maybe charge a
fake I'll be in charge of killing myself
don't worry about this guys hold on
stop the fire stop fire oh jeez oh bomb
oh boy it's okay we that guy's the bomb
sorry I will die as many times as I need
to put yourself on the line for this
yeah for the team I can't tell if we're
just doing this randomly or for actually
doing a good job I like I like the there
is no sense to the madness we're just
killing for sport hey play we're gonna
play
going back to play video games like game
rack store I don't know lady so what am
i coming back gosh we shot I shot a
couple with you guys Mario Kart that was
true you and Michelle we're commentating
and that was color commentary it was
amazing we're killing this guy's
yeah you're just hanging out what's my
favorite game to play right now I just
beat Bastion which was awesome you guys
that's really fun actually I'm really
really really close friends with the
soul whoa wow that's awesome I love that
did you play that game what did you
choose at the end which did you do
greater good or did you go personal not
cuz not a sporting that's not a sport
I'm a greater good too but I felt like I
didn't do the right right now this is
how I dial my phone by the way also when
you get angry and hang up you can't be
like it's the arms cross just teleport
to you I'm just yeah what part know if
you guys can have a superpower and not a
not including these I mean including
these but also like any other power what
would it be to been techno gotta be more
specific about that that's what one
character has that ability like you when
you like in stop time okay stopping time
stop it is this how you would do it too
like this they would tie my arms
together yes Amelia what about you oh I
like telekinesis that would be dope just
like great so be the force basically you
wish you had of course oh yeah
I love that Stephan spaghetti fingers
now what is so that's why we call it
that that's why we call you spaghetti
fingers that's Morosky there you go
don't worry about we'll take care of it
ladies don't worry about the guys got
this I was just like god it would be
kind of great
is it the processor dying or the game
like that Jesus spaghetti fingers and it
wasn't even Ridge '''l original power
farting backwards farting there's a bad
smell and suck it up into my but that's
that's a power
hey guys still Oh God oh who put fish in
the microwave at work got this guy's
yeah
what's a reverse fart sound like
something like a record skipping yeah
what helpful but helpful yeah let's go I
wish that I could be a storage unit like
you I just put things inside you are
like a pouch of holding I can judge it
drag it to you
then I'd suck you right in yeah I'd love
you forever from the inside that's
that's her weaknesses she's never able
to love yeah that's the only I like I'm
like rogue yes I can't touch my friends
exactly okay so I need to get over there
and then I can like ice ice block me bro
not to talk about barding Oh what
happened there
drop sorry you know I can do I can
remote detonate the ice block to make it
go up okay cool let's do that are we
able to go up to the top up there I
would need to do that I can teleport
well I mean I can oh you can move things
to Meghan can we get that can we get
them I still am unclear on where I got
it didn't even need old ice block blegh
there was a guy not to bring it back to
farting which is why there's this guy
named LaPenta Bane who's a real person
who looked at me pathetic who is a real
person who is called Liffe artiste he
was French and people he was so funny
people died at his performances he
outsold Houdini at Moulin Rouge
Tamura Houdini said I'm never gonna
perform there again because he was so
embarrassed
and his lack he would do like animal
sounds like with farting he would do
like impressions of animals and he for
his climax this is a real thing and you
should link to it bet on Wikipedia I
want people to know about this guy on
for his climax he would do that the 90
nose is oppressive the 1907 earthquake
in San Francisco with farts
I swear to god that's a real person
amazing parties over here here we go
it's somebody pushing the thing
whoa that seemed aggressive okay here we
go
I thought Brian put same as the parties
no dude lahpet Amane was the fart east
like in late 1800s Brian Posehn
although I do love Brian yeah there we
go
there we go how did wait how does this
work oh it just stops randomly kill
myself
don't drop that don't we're trying range
aid just tell us bleh doesn't really do
anything it's job via the time to look
that up yeah well getting up the thing
get up - get up - think I'll take a week
okay it's just us email kt9 what's up
how's it going once but it was great a
video game for video games once yeah
that's right who thought that I got to
see some sweet peacocks here's what I
sought the mansion peacocks there's a
lot of animals there some monkeys very
cute monkeys
although the monkeys kind of freaked me
out because there's like let's say 30 or
50 tiny little monkeys I died right and
I just had this image of them like
skeletonizing a deer oh nice oh well
done what else do I see there a lot of
parrots there's a lot of parrots at the
mansion there's a trampoline there nice
little koi pond
the string across this and the birds
don't get it three playmates there I
consider myself an honorary playmate you
know played play dude bleh bleh um one
thing that was really funny that I
didn't tell you guys I guess was how's
this working
what does that switch to here somebody
want to get on that and jump okay great
exactly I was gonna say cuz hey somebody
shoot me into the green stuff thank you
alright somebody get on that and I can
shoot him over maybe is that gonna help
anybody Oh where'd you go oh there you
can you can you jump kitty-corner over
to that one but no we need we need okay
okay no wait let's do another block
thing it's another block thing okay I
think we know that the weakest link of
these four laughing oh good idea great
idea
hit it alright sorry we did it now suck
it suck it over there
suck it over there no okay great now how
do we get it over teleport right I think
that's too far to talk alright
Oh perfect oh please take a seat
Pamela very nice to meet you all right
all right that's right everybody penning
I don't know why I'm here okay all right
where are these lovely ladies were
that's right that's right that there's
some of our playing game called tiny
brains which is uh we're all lab animals
trying to get a block we're trying to
get stop for a second and let me talk to
the ladies this is a huge event for me
you're both very beautiful it's nice to
see you I just wanted to have make eye
contact with both of you are you looking
at the screen I'm completely asexual
then we're out made they they host a web
series called gamer next door on player
combo they play video games yeah that's
right that's the draw and their
playmates yes but for me no you're as
human beings is the draw that's right
we're not put a label on yourself you
don't need any label that's for me I
like the fact that play the tubes get
lost
yes let me get some wine in here I want
a Pinot Noir that's right very nice say
say hi to the chat say hi to the chat
hey chat how's it going yo what's going
on up a monk 89 and Teddy B and chemical
blunt and that's right Johnny three two
one who's misspelling my name the fun
you know just it's a good time with all
you guys that's gonna see you again all
right so so a here's we all had
different powers wait which one is he
which one are you
you're this guy I'm that guy oh no are
you the teleporter no he's the pro
you're this anyway this is your area of
expertise and you don't know what's
happening no I don't understand we've
never played this game none of us have
played no we're all learning how to play
okay so we all do different things and
we're trying to get this block over to
that that square up there why
get back over there that's a good
question wait which one am i I'm number
three I'm in the corner and I'm just
sort of yeah we have to take this block
yeah and we have to get it over there
yes I have one suggestion yeah FedEx
yeah
FedEx it so we're yeah so here so if you
hit okay so you if you hit don't do it
now but if you hit r2 you'll you can you
like yell and and it shoots it'll shoot
the block across okay so but don't do it
now don't do it right now so oh wait no
make make the block all right let's lock
up so I can I can pull the no no no I
need to what is that right there what
did you just make I'm happen so that's
me I make an ice block right that's my
power that goes of that saying Amelia
okay its power is to teleport okay and
Pamela's power is to suck things toward
the opposite ear apart she sucks alright
and what do I do and you you're gonna
push things for it's alright so stay
there stay there and I'll I'll make what
am I gonna do I'm gonna make the block I
know make the block um honor it what do
you you need to put it elevated no no
what we can do is get me over to that
top one and then when he puts the block
up over and they push it over I can suck
it you can just push the block wait you
should hey we just push it over in just
a second this is I don't see how
anyone's having fun what environment are
we in this looks terrible this looks
like a Matt walks Coonskin is game I
hate this game
waffle what are we doing and we're here
with these two beautiful women and like
an idiot we can play you're gonna quit
play soccer you just wanna play soccer
I'd like to take them to line I'd like
to take these ladies to a three-hour
lunch I'd like you to get lost I don't
want to I don't want to play this game
yeah alright what lo I'm not happy
portugal says hi
what where'd you go hello portugal good
to see you
alright let's just can we try this yes
let's try it okay you can suck it all
right wait you need to be over there to
sucker
we need to get you over there first all
right I'm gonna make that okay wait
let's push this out of the way you get
can you get up behind her yes I can get
out of ice block don't keep jumping into
the green you launched me up what did
you do that for I was all right hold on
okay we don't get other things don't get
on it don't get on all right she's on
you know I gotta do I'm gonna paste
Rosalie in the back I'm just pacing now
okay okay okay so now go behind the okay
wait wait okay okay
yeah face right now press r2 which ones
are to get this one this one okay do it
yeah what was I doing
face face face that way turn around
there you hit it oh that's okay
don't jump into the dope please let's
try it let's try it again okay here we
go
she's really as a clueless yeah all
right here we go okay okay do it yes
what kind of crap this is a Christian
network
this is awful Hey we're really sorry
this is awful
alright but let's just we could just
play sorry you should we just planned
try play tonin ruins everything
we're gonna play soccer we're gonna try
to play soccer that was awful alright
here we go
I think I'd say alright we're good to go
play soccer here we go you do what you
gotta do let's talk so we like to do
what are your hobbies
forget that
art music okay very nice very nice
all right all right here tip you guys
pick the other two or you do you want to
be on a teammate with one a team with
one of the playmates how should we
divide up guys versus girls from no I
think we're together all right fine all
right okay all right we're gonna be red
team do I pick go to the right
you're already yeah okay perfect all
right now let's start game all right
here we go all right in the opposing
team's goal here we go jump create fly
my four I'm gonna just go towards ya the
other goal I don't know which one I know
I'm the wrong one
I'm one okay what are we doing we're
getting it towards that I'm red you
Amelia you and I are red yeah whoa wait
a sec wait here we go we're going down
you're going up we're going down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh no no no no no yes there we go up the
side there we go
I'm like Ronaldo Conan's hair lights
play I want to read them the light I
want to read mantastic ladies I gotta go
I gotta go and I gotta it was so nice to
meet you both
get out bleh take a hike yeah let's get
a picture here I want a copy I'm gonna
tell people that's my prom photo and
then I explain why I aged so terribly
all right
kicked out of my own stream Jesus sorry
thanks Cody that was really fun
all right look we still got 20 minutes I
think we could beat this level or should
we end the stream I think we could do it
that was unfair no we took a break but
we're back first of all I just want to
let you guys know I let Conan win there
I don't know if you heard he said I'd be
fired if I'd stopped didn't stop
blasting him I just want everybody to
know no I mean actually I was right
that's a good you know what wha well
let's just play this game should we just
wait let's just play the game all right
everybody's back here we go I'm the blue
guy man
carefully but we might need to finish
off let's try to be this level we might
need to finish I might need to lose
weight good player three are you just
going over our loss in your mind over
and over okay we have to do it all over
again okay so how about I immediately go
right one now we go I'm the blue one now
how did this happen Peter nine nine nine
err please we know color is based better
than you at video games yes up thank you
sorry about the sweat alright okay I'm
back I'm back to the same when I was
before all right cool everybody's back
to normal alright here we go
me right sorry kill myself I think no
this is how we did we did it before he's
yeah do it and then I'll I'll I'll jump
you up at the end
hey stock collage knuckle that's a crazy
name how do you even say that shocked a
lot dude you got I hope that's not like
your last name because I feel anybody
else want a free trip across the green
stuff wait somebody gets on that button
over there yeah actually we have two
cents of doing it didn't do it hit it
dude sorry nailed it
rusha skate at the end of the video here
we go here we go oh can you move the
camera to the top corner someone's
asking you can't see good question well
I'm right here we go there we go on the
ledge teleport needs to stay agreed now
that's not Tina Fey the falconer said
that's right
although justice challenges here we go
bill have you guys can't seen kimmy
schmitt by the way Tina Fey oh that's
true what do i do okay ready
there we go I'm finally after 16 levels
getting the hang of my powers thanks
it's better you're welcome thank you
should knock a Locka Locka Locka doodle
okay both of you guys just died okay we
don't want to die though we want her to
be over there because we want to do we
got to put it on the Block no I think
I'm pretty sure I can just I can just
launch it all right okay well at least
get it closer then to the top part I
heard if every card Dart
I heard that everybody jumps in a lot at
this exact same time there's a secret I
don't believe you because you're the
Internet eats me on a block though it
needs to be it needs to be elevated it's
so Mikey oh whoa what happened there I
can grab it even if it's not on a book
you need to stay on the can't get on
them just just push the block nice
Tim Tim Tim do you actually learned all
the stories the games before close game
or do you know them all from memory I
learned them I don't know I I didn't
know all the stuff about winter weight
Dyson sorry what games you guys most
excited that are coming out is that like
there's a third-person shooter but
instead of shooting each other with guns
oh that's awesome
cover the map with ink and you can turn
into a squid that's it it's it's a
shooter game - so can you use use the
Wii Remote right to like aim it stuff
yeah that's awesome
what's the game I'm thinking of the Wii
game where it's like oh you're like
building castles out of like goo World
of Goo he's a world of you yeah oh yeah
that game is have you guys ever plays I
can't help but feel responsible
all right you want to jump ready
sorry yeah great job
Oh Oh pants a very big hole I let me get
it wait Amelia can teleport yeah yes you
can only do it perfect yes hey so tell
the people at home so for those of you
who are not Playboy Playmates
explain how you get to be a Playboy
Playmate can Stephen and I be Playboy
Playmates
no why not uni male titties well okay so
it's six out of ten for us on that count
up and then what happens like what's the
application process you got right but
that's it's not just getting naked I
mean or else anybody it's different for
different girls for me photographer
found me in one and two
okay cool so that you get it's kind of
like you get submitted some girls
actually go to casting calls others will
send in their pictures some try to get
into the mansion by climbing a fence
that's awesome and then so and then what
happens from there you go into the
Playboy studios if you test
[Music]
whoa
all right good lord don't let that ever
happen again they were so angry yeah so
after half of prudes
that's awesome that's crazy and so you
guys did you guys meet have you guys
picking me huh and and he seems like a
pretty chill dude he's the chillest he's
like the definition of chill he's really
he's a really nice guy he really cares
about the play needs and about his wife
Crystal that's awesome now I see a gamer
does he play any video games okay
perfect
Marsten actually like helped have
Marsden that's such a cool name I got
earring yeah just ask people to start
calling me Marston that's the coolest
name ever yeah I think it's pretty dope
Mason is a cool name also too ridiculous
but yeah so mark said what he's MRSA
like to play um he likes to play League
of Legends a lot very Super Smash
Brothers oh my god perfect I just
actually got it I just got a 3ds XL so I
was like three
oh yeah yeah by the way Nintendo get
your stuff together man you just called
it the new I will spot the old oh my god
I'm about the old one it's literally
called new the new 3dsxl oh my god
there's so many adjectives there 3ds XL
new yeah exactly the new new new ones
that's a double new how we met we met
make tourney and we're like okay which
TS do you have she's like the DA the 3ds
I'm like which which was like there's
the regular PDS is the new 3ds yeah so
she's like no the new 3ds XL 2.0 is
slash whatever old keyboard slash 4k
old-school today it is pretty dope
though I gotta say like the the 3d is
like mine that face that's crazy makes
me create so fun
what's your favorite game to plan the
new Xenoblade Chronicles is pretty great
that's a fun one tingles down below I
[Music]
know yeah it's like the Wii U after the
Wii that's true like you didn't have to
count the Wii U you could have called it
like something completely different like
the Wii 2 electric Boogaloo yeah cuz you
would want to do like you know yes they
you only think I would like to see from
gaming companies like like they do with
operating systems like the lion or the
leopard like put a little jazz into it
like even like car companies got cool
thing like the Ford Focus is like the
lamest car ever but the Ford Focus
sounds really cool yeah like I would hey
man what do you plan on oh I'm playing
on the ps4 all take 10 percent thank you
[Music]
see that's cool wait we got to get the
[Music]
wait you don't have your color man
whoops oh sorry
nice job I'm helping you deal not yeah
I'm not doing any you're doing not leave
the room with all the ones with cool
names died that's true the Jaguar died
yeah Jaguar died Atari died but Atari
what I guess is the name of the company
it's pretty Saturn Saturn died you're
right Dreamcast yeah geez maybe there's
a reason yeah I could look hey or Nick
that you bring up a great point this
game is called tiny brains for just
joining us we're here to Playboy
Playmates Amelia Talan a Pamela Horton
follow them add Amelie talent and Pamela
Horton 13 on all social media as well as
check out there awesome web series gamer
next door which I'm on today at
youtube.com slash game register as well
as on Playboy Con which I saw a bunch of
awesome see that was a great lob boys
she deploys you boys she didn't add in
the team this looks really dangerous
cool
my life wannabe oh it's slowly going
inside oh man this is gonna suck alright
checking
oh yeah wait we get on the thing
get on the put the thing on the thing
Pamela's the only person yin and Amelia
to get on the thing there we go nice I
may enjoy a trip across nice nice good
job good job
the ladies are carrying us on this one
for sure
[Music]
you want me to put it on the thing oh
Jesus I'm sorry I just I know that's
much you know that's my real superpowers
is I think things up let's just give up
guys stop it no Amelia we've got to do
this we can do it you do it I believe in
us Nathan you say so many nays oh nice
job nice job single hand is killing it
okay Maya nice job I mean terrible job
Chevy Regal hello what's going on here
we go there we go you know what maybe I
could put it on a block and shoot it up
and get it over the thing way over you
know what let's work a little weight
let's work a little bit of head here
wait somebody yeah Amelia Amelia yeah
here jump on the thing and then shoot it
shooter across shooter across somebody's
ear sorry
Oh No oh yes yes wait wait you do it do
it do it wait wait yes oh man that was
tough oh no no no no so now we need to
get across can we just jump that yeah
what's that block comes out it doesn't
actually go all the way back in does it
oh there we go
there's Conan smell like cocoa butter no
he smells like nervous cheese I think
it's how he's described his own smell
wouldn't you say wouldn't you say
you guys got to hug him he's never
hugged me in my whole life smells like
Coco Pops Lula Farley I denied her
tingles like 7 oh my god really look
here you know what mega tingles there we
go nobody gets the mega tingles but a
million what oh yeah whoa dude meta
we're on camera on camera on camera
triple cameras I love it I love it
nervous cheese Konev is here I'm sorry
you missed him
it's Damien Damien II but you can watch
this past broadcast oh yeah wait Twitter
handles Pamela more than 13 Emilia
talents right Blair snakes and rats
follow my Instagram its sleeve Smith its
all right need to get over there I'll do
that and then give me a nice block
thanks cool hit it so oh good save
hey I'm being nice to Amelia be nice to
me Lea know that now that someone's
noticed nothing I call up on the chair
okay wait you need to make a nice block
so you can shoot it well I think we have
to send somebody else across first
yeah - suck it over there here yeah
should we send you across yeah ii don't
see - suck it over there when the thing
goes up how do we get that right yes
okay so we need to get him on that left
one shoot a nice block so she can be
behind it and then we'll shoot the block
over there
then shoot another ice block at that and
she wait till that there's an ice block
do your thing okay no no make another
ice block here's another yes all right
okay so now now another ice block not
wall no we don't need another ice bar oh
really oh wait yes we do ah but get it
ready oh no I shouldn't
no no you're fine you're fine oh another
ice block to shoot up anything suck it
suck it suck it suck it suck it suck it
suck it suck it okay sorry here we go
whoops sideways into the muck it up yeah
[Music]
there we go all right I spot nicer those
two items to it prepare the ice block
okay all right here we go shoot it
across no I'm gonna wait for that to go
okay yeah yeah tips activity yeah now
that you called me out I'm nice that's
true okay you ready all right here we go
nailed it ice block shoot it over BAM
yes she's dead yes let's do it
she's back it's a beautiful thing all
right this I think this is our last
level guys so let's make it a good one
okay
the team buck here we go give me some
kind of death happening in a second some
kind of said I want the pizza it's like
dr. Mario is running this thing hashtag
last level salad oh it's just a fun time
oh that's good yeah know what you do
need to decompress it's pretty stressful
being an animal in this lab again about
me yeah pushes well you know what I'll
make an ice block well it's get in front
of the ice block Stephen get behind ants
block
all right well the only person that
didn't have to go over went over
I'm just get killed real quick anyway
you can teleport with me so I can do the
same thing in Reverse like switch with
me me I can just no she gets like she'll
just get killed okay yes we did it
alright I think that's the last level
ladies guys thank you so much for
joining us thank you - Pamela Horton
Amelia Talan
from Playboy follow Pamela Pamela Horton
13 and Amelia Amelia Talent on all
social things please go to youtube.com
slash gamer next door to see their
awesome web series that I'm up and
subscribe mofos and see more of bleh
and/or conan at the mansion just blow up
our chin that's right blow up the chin
and check out flavor calm because they
have a bunch of awesome safe word
content thank you guys for joining us we
will see you next week
[Music]